bonjour noah manoir vous êtes ancien
fonctionnaire jour de police merci
d'être avec nous ce matin tout d'abord
qu'est-ce que vous inspire cette affaire
alors en fait comme dans toutes les
affaires judiciaires et toutes celles
qui sont en particulier médiatisés ils
sont toujours savoir lire entre les
lignes
comme je le dis assez fréquemment alors
cette affaire est sortie hier par le
canal est l'intermédiaire de la chaîne
d'information bfm tv et on a eu droit
effectivement sur ce dossier à une
communication officielle de la
directrice de l'igpn brigitte jullien
donc permettez moi de saisir l'occasion
de remercier brigitte jullien directrice
de l'igpn parce que il faut savoir que
son institution rend un rapport annuel
devant les journalistes à l'occasion
d'une conférence de presse donc qui a
organisé par le ministère de l'intérieur
et cette conférence a eu lieu avant-hier
c'est à dire mardi 20 juillet et comme
par hasard donc au lendemain de cette
conférence de presse on à l'émergence de
cette affaire par la thermique de bfm tv
donc de violences policières qui
finalement serait avérée et
aboutirait à la mise en examen de ces
trois policiers donc si vous voulez y a
pas de hasard dans le calendrier
au moment justement de donc de la remise
de la communication de ce rapport annuel
de l'igpn il faut savoir que cette
institution a été conspué par tous les
spécialistes et tous les journalistes
présents dont mediapart qui avait titré
sur un article je seek la directive de
l'igpn reconnaît son soutien aux
policiers
donc alors en fait par cette
reconnaissance tacite
si vous voulez madame julien signe la
fin de l'igpn ni plus ni moins parce
qu'en fait l'igpn n'est pas là pour
soutenir les policiers l'igpn est la
face et la police des polices tout en
principe ce serait presque le contraire
mais en fait elle est la cible et les
gps et une juridiction elle est là pour
soutenir la justice et le droit en fait
elle est pas là pour soutenir une
corporation de cas partir du moment où
elle a complètement éludé les affaires
de violences policières dans son rapport
annuel
brigitte jullien en fait à quelque part
si vous voulez signer le début de la fin
finalement de l'igpn est donc cette
affaire qui est en réalité une
gesticulation parce que finalement au
lendemain de cette de ce tollé
médiatique on nous sort comme ça une
affaire j'ai réchauffer un vieux dossier
bon de ce qui s'est passé argenteuil
on va plutôt revenir sur sur sur la
terre en elle-même on le disait nouvelle
affaire de violences policières on voit
de plus en plus à ce genre d'affaires
être médiatisé ces derniers temps je
voulais savoir tout simplement s'il
existait un sentiment un certain
sentiment d'impunité chez certains
policiers
je le disais tout à l'heure 27 décharge
de taser en dix minutes
bien sûr alors permettez-moi de
rectifier votre propos cette affaire
n'est pas nouvelle elle date de quelques
mois déjà
et effectivement bon c'est une affaire
de violences policières parmi d'autres
j'ai envie de dire mais elle a été
sélectionnée par l'igpn pour communiquer
alors si vous voulez effectivement va
revenir sur cette affaire et qu'est ce
qu'on apprend on apprend que les
policiers sont mises en examen
donc une mise en examen ce n'est
absolument pas une condamnation une mise
en examen c'est simplement une
notification par un juge d'instruction
que les policiers sont mises en examen
dans le cadre de ce qu'on appelle une
information judiciaire
ça signifie qu'à la deux
du parquet l'afer a été mise entre les
mains d'un juge d'instruction et non pas
justement entre les mains de l'igpn
comme ça aurait pu émettre le cas du
15h27 impulsion de tazer en 40 minutes
permettez moi effectivement de
m'indigner mais ça paraît tellement
évident que c'est presque pas nécessaire
lequel en 27 impulsion de taser comment
est ce qu'on sait c'est parce qu'il faut
savoir que cette arme non létale qu'est
le tazer est couplé à un système de
vidéosurveillance qu'à chaque fois qu'on
utilise le tazer ont déclenché de façon
automatique une caméra qui témoignent
des faits et qui peut justement
témoigner de la bonne utilisation ou pas
du tazer donc alors sous jacente à cette
affaire on a celle de ce policier dont
on a retrouvé la photo en bas résille
avec un short en cuir et du maquillage
donc la vraie question c'est aussi de se
poser la question savoir six policiers
un peu aujourd'hui exercer ses fonctions
dans une zone sensible et impressionner
les voyous quand il a été justement
confondues dans cette posture même s'il
est défendu par l'institution par le
cadre privé on dit cette photo a été
prise dans le cadre privé mais à mon
sens ça va être extrêmement compliqué
pour lui de continuer à exercer
on nous dit que les policiers sont
suspendus alors encore une fois moi je
lis entre les lignes il faut savoir
monsieur que la suspension à titre
conservatoire c'est une sanction
disciplinaire certes mais il faut savoir
que le salaire de ces policiers est
systématiquement rétabli au quatrième
mois c'est à dire que dans l' enquête et
dans l'attenté des résultats de
l'instruction les policiers sont encore
payées à rester chez eux ne s'est pas
vraiment une sanction administrative
comme celles qu'on peut avoir à l'issue
d'un conseil de discipline
il faut savoir que l'administration ne
s'est toujours pas prononcé au plan
disciplinaire sur le sort de ces
policiers alors qu'elle a largement la
possibilité de ceux de les révoquer
compte tenu des indices graves et des
éléments probants qui ont permis
justement l'ouverture de l'information
judiciaire
nous voilà est alors faits extrêmement
graves au cir les policiers ont constaté
au moment du contrôle d'identité
la présence de cette photo sur téléphone
portable du jeune qui a été contrôlé il
faut savoir que l'on a maintenant je me
permets de vous ben est malheureusement
bien sûr on manque de temps
on ne manquera pas bien sûr de vous
inviter une prochaine fois pour pour
revenir sur cette affaire en tout cas
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce matin et
comme je vous le disais on ne manquera
pas de devoir inviter pour pour évoquer
cette affaire une prochaine fois merci